By 77 year old mother recently had triple bypass surgery and was diagnosed with hemipromatosis
or GP and cardiologist suggests there's no connection.
What are your thoughts on hemipromatosis?
I would agree that there's quite possibly no connection, so hemipromatosis is quite common.
We used to diagnose hemipromatosis a lot when we did a lot of genetic, there was a time
in history where we were one of the only clinics that were doing genetic, full genetic, good
genetic workups.
I was doing, gosh, multiple a day and I would diagnose hemipromatosis because there's
a gene for that.
Okay, so the reason why I personally have hemipromatosis is because of a genetic variant and tell
people that they need to deal with that, give them some natural ways to deal with that.
But almost nobody knew they had it, so it rarely brings symptoms, so that's not uncommon
and it could be completely unrelated to the need for the triple bypass surgery, which was
locked arteries, which I would be more suggestive looking at.
Of course, it had a bypass surgery, you know, you have damaged arterial walls and then you
go what damage the arterial walls is at high polycystine levels, that was never checked,
was this person never getting blood tested.
Was it H-Pylorite that was never diagnosed, never investigated, was a product by, was it
heavy metals, those were three biggies for endothelial disorder, which is what we're talking
about there.
You said it's called a Cyrex panel to do with 7-year-old who said, is there any other test
team blood work?
Yeah, so I'm just, I'm just throwing that out there, I'm not your doctor, so if you go on
our chronic disease and autoimmune site, you'll see the possible test team, again, talking
over with your doctor, otherwise you can make an appointment on our clinic, or more specific
things to do.